[Music]
good afternoon and welcome to our
session today can you all hear me okay
this is going to be a little different
from my normal talks that actually have
a room so we're gonna keep it
high-energy so welcome to our talk this
afternoon on see what's new with cloud
spanner
my name is the P Shrivastav I am the
product manager for cloud spanner and
I'm very excited to have you all join me
for this session so let's move on
sorry the background is a little
distracting but let's move so before we
get into the new part let's talk about
what cloud spanner is right what have we
been doing so far so we launched cloud
spanner externally on the GCP platform
last year on Valentine's Day and then we
quickly went to general availability and
in the last 14 or so months we've seen
some great traction on it but but before
clock spanner was there right you had to
choose what database you wanted based on
the one really important attribute of
your database that you couldn't give up
so either it was performance or scale or
sequel or relational semantics however
you want to put it or manageability
right or or or or or and with cloud
spanner basically you don't have to make
those compromises anymore it is our no
compromise a database that combines the
benefits of both horizontal scale and
performance and the familiar relational
semantics that you're used to with
sequel NC 2011 compliant sequel dialect
table schemas everything you're used to
in like about relational databases so we
launched and are currently available in
13 GCP regions we also have multi region
configurations and they give you four
and five nines of availability which
means five nines really means less than
five minutes of downtime a year so if
you've gone upstairs and see
in Moscow New West the 59 which is our
SAE lounge it's worth visiting but
basically we are highly reliable highly
available database service offered on on
Google table platform right so um so so
why talk spanner and and how are we
releasing it to the world right so as I
said spanner combines the benefits of
many different types of systems so that
you don't have to make those compromises
anymore but databases have existed for
30 years right so we could have started
to add a whole bunch of features to to
our database that we launched last year
but we wanted to be deliberate about how
we go about adding features and
functionality to spanner right our
philosophy with cloud spanner from the
beginning has been building for you for
our customers right we have been using
this system internally for multiple
years but so it's not something that we
picked up and threw over the fence and
said hey have fun with it
right it's not just a cool tech but it's
actually useful and we launched with our
basic functionality that we did and then
we wanted to add features as we go based
on how customers perceived it and wanted
from it so we have been deliberate and
that's something that I will talk about
as we go but you should tell us what you
want us to build next so you can find me
on LinkedIn obviously but please tell us
on Stack Overflow on those two headings
and and we'd love to know what more
you'd like from the system so as I said
we launched about 14 inch months ago and
what have we we've been doing as we're
being deliberate about adding
functionality right so we added
multi-region configurations again this
is something that's very popular
internally but we wanted to make sure
that we provided this functionality only
if it was useful to our external
customers and turns out it was a very
high demand feature so we added it late
last year we also have admin and data
access logging we have stackdriver
integrations and metrics and more
metrics coming we keep adding metrics
based on what you all are looking for
rather than oh here's a whole bunch of
metrics and now
figure out how to tune your system based
on it we have a very cool feature again
that was internally used but also looks
like it's very useful externally which
is commit timestamps that we launched
earlier this year and that allows you to
basically log transactionally when a
transaction committed right so as part
of a transaction to a row you can
actually write the timestamp at which
that transaction committed which allows
you to build many many things like
change launch triggers you know change
in a capture etc on top of it we also
have open census integration for more
debugging again and then of course
compliance certification and the list
goes on but but these are some of the
things that again were asked for and
we've tried to deliver deliberately so
before we move on cloud expand has seen
tremendous adoption across all industry
and across all verticals and I'm so
excited to have one of our very cool
customers here today from Belgium to
tell us more about their use case
Marc is from Nexus health and and he's
gonna tell us a little bit more about
how they're using spanner so Marc take
it away so hello so my name is Marc Marc
for now Giada I'm from Nexus health and
I just give you a little overview of
what we are and what we do so probably
you don't know is Belgium small country
somewhere in Europe we play it very well
in the cup they say and in Belgium there
is a large University Hospital it's
called use at Logan it's quite a large
University and training hospital it's
about 2,000 bats and about 9,000 medical
staff and there is all centralized IT so
we do everything centralized so nothing
is decentralized and we do it with about
180 hats currently over the last 25
years we've been building our own
internal electronic medical record
system and that we call internally the
clinical work station and it's it was
important from the very beginning that
is the one-stop for everything you do
with a patient
data so not just for the physicians but
also for the nursing for the
administrative people etc as everybody
in inside its patient centric and it's
very very very workflow oriented so it
has a big burden on workflow also on the
database and so all of it for those who
are familiar give lots of functionality
not just the classical medical report
but lots of other things like planning
and order entry and drugs prescription
and administration etc etc so a complete
and patient management system so that
was quite successful over the last 25
years and we rolled it out gradually in
that large academic Hospital it was so
successful that a lot of other hospitals
in the region said whoa why can't we
have that system why don't you sell it
to us we said well we don't sell it yet
at that moment it was 10 years ago so we
said why don't you just join us and and
we're not going to do to sell it and
give you the CD and install it with you
just join us in the same database and
act like you're working in our hospital
but just on another side so at that time
it was just by accident that we said
well go and sit into it at one big
system but gradually it evolved in a
very important thing namely that we
build a one central medical file across
the complete region of Flanders with all
patient data in there centrally without
having the difficulty of connecting
between all different systems so it
makes that it's a very big offering so
you optimize across across hospitals
workflows and data flow so whenever you
enter data here it's automatically at
the other side and there's no data going
across it's a big advantage in flounders
so currently there's about 30 hospitals
connected to that twenty ones are
currently in full production the other
ones are still connected to it so as I
said it's one big shared medical record
that currently about 13,000 that's
managed in that system and that are
30,000 named users in the system and
every three minutes
they're about 6,000 users active in the
database so that is the current set up
and well we grow fast over the last
years for those who are a bit familiar
with geography
this is Belgium northern part so some of
you will recognize in the center there
is Brussels some of you have heard of
that and also there is something like
Antwerp Ghent and Bruges you're familiar
with that so over the last ten years all
of a sudden we were across flounders and
across flounders that when you live at
at sea at the coast and you have a very
big problem medical problem you are sent
to that big Central Hospital somewhere
around Brussels in Leuven and they
automatically have all your medical data
there so and it's a big plus and after
you afterwards you go back you go back
home and all data is transferred
automatically again and it's a big plus
so but what does it mean we currently
have about 50% of the Belgium patients
bats and hospitals in that system also
it's all in one big database well Wow
and it does about 1 million plus
transactions a day so that is that set
up the current architecture is quite
quite classical so we do it all
ourselves it's basically a client-server
architecture so with a very big one
central instance database in the middle
that is core to everything and then
connect it of course to the clients
either the laptops or there is mobile
applications or there is a health
connections etc etcetera it's all driven
by that one big data base as you can
imagine we grow a bit fast and it wasn't
envisioned to be that big so there is a
big risk on that and what do we need we
we said ok let's look for a new solution
that is more future proof and that we
can grow even further but we have a lot
of constraints currently and as you can
see size is an important stuff so of
course we are about 14 terabytes of
online data in there we do not do any
archiving in there availability of
course for a hospital very very
important you could live with the
computers
for a minute during a very important
surgery but ten minutes whoa that will
be a problem so you will not have that
scalability in our environment is really
important because those 30 hospitals
will not be the end of it we will only
grow over that and of course you can
imagine security in a hospital this is a
prime thing we have very complex
transactions and just to give you an
idea into in that system we have about
seven thousand tables with about 5000
triggers that have three hundred
thousand lines of sequel codes and
managing all that complexity of
transactions another big thing that we
have is we do weekly releases
consistently over the last 25 years and
we want to keep that because it's very
important all things of new ideas pop up
in the healthcare also in healthcare
deletion less data is very important
every data that goes in never gets
deleted updated or anything it just
needs to remain there we need to know at
every moment in time what the status of
the patient was and we can't need to do
go back for that and we have no
maintenance window as I just said you
can be down for one to two three minutes
but going down for longer than that is
not an option in a hospital of course
this is a big challenge for us and so we
want that burden somebody else's problem
and not our problem anymore so we looked
at around and what can we do just to
give you an idea of what we currently do
with our system so we have that one big
big database as I said but of course
technically it's all a set up of three
logical servers being logically
replicated to each other just to make
sure that one is the primary server but
whenever something goes wrong you can
quickly switch to another server and
then another use the user will not see
that but also it's it's structurally
done for doing maintenance because I say
we don't have a maintenance window but
that's that says that the user doesn't
want to see a maintenance window but of
course you as a DB admin you need to do
maintenance so how do you do that we
keep those three servers up and running
so one is the primary and the two other
are hot standbys but not only that we
also have warm standbys because those
standbys there are hot standbys it means
that whenever you do something logically
wrong and the primary server it
automatically gets replicated within
seconds or at most a minute to the other
servers and then the accident is is gone
and you do not have the data so
therefore we currently have that setup
of warm standbys where you lag about an
hour or a day and to make sure that you
can just retrieve in case of a logical
error the data there and then a part of
that from that of course you have all
the other copies for doing development
for doing testing for doing training and
cetera that read only for clinical
trials and so on and so on so we now
envision a new application and the
application is not just for the
hospitals where but we're immediately
going to attract also the first line so
we're also going to go to the primary
care so the family doctors GPS home
nursing etcetera etc into that system so
all your data is automatically connected
we call it demo upper it's a very very
unsexy name I know but it's an acronym
for something that stuck inside and we
say it's the mother of all patient
records so that's what we're trying to
build and therefore we needed a big
stable and good solution for the backend
so what is our current actual
architecture that we're building in the
front end we have angular environments
talks in the middle tier two ago and
middle tier it's all nicely connected
with the G RPC and in the Google cloud
platform it's always very nice to have
that reiterations over and over again
from your API so as we are currently
developing continuously and in the back
it's driven by cloud spanner of course
apart from that we also have a pops up
to go to the Google bigquery and there
we do currently our requirement of the
deletion less data so that we can always
track all versions of the data that were
ever there of course our DBA s as
typical D base of an on parameter
environment are they're very
scary about the cloud solutions they say
well will this really work so they did a
lot of extensive performance testing and
so on and someone to make sure that yes
this will work and so they just give me
some overviews of testing that I did and
they basically said whatever we try it
with cloud spanner it just scales
linearly so no worries this will work
for us so we're very happy to have been
working with the team and now it's back
to UDP okay you can't get better than
mother of all patient records right so
thank you Mark he'll be here later on
for questions if you have any more
details and we also are joined by Bart
from Bill's Belgium so we can get into
that in the Q&A section
but now let's actually move on to why
you all are here which is to learn more
about what's what's new so again going
back to our products the last year of
building what you all and our customers
have been asking for the first question
I guess asks and the second and the
tenth is what about disaster recovery so
I'm very happy to talk about our launch
last week of our import export
functionality and it it allows you to do
a bunch of different use cases not just
disaster recovery but the highlights
here are that it's a UI functionality
that's push-button so you can take a
consistent dump of your spanner database
and put it by default in a GCS bucket
using our Apache bean based dataflow
connectors and it's stored in default by
default in our Apache Avro format which
is again another open source format and
again with the push of a button you can
import the data back into cloud spanner
so what this does is allows you to take
your own backups at your convenience and
store them in a different medium to get
even better understanding like better
separation of concerns here it also
enables a couple of other interesting
use cases which is you
can actually take this dump this export
of your production clouds manner
database and use it for dev test
environment so you can load it into a
different environment for Debian testing
you can do database configuration moves
what I mean by that is you can export a
cloud spanner data out and put it in a
different configuration because
ultimately you can import it into any
any cloud spanner configuration that you
want so it allows you to go from one
configuration to another okay
it also allows you to do things like
export it out and then allow bigquery to
do analytics on your on your data base
as well so it makes it a little bit
easier so you don't have to ETL it
necessarily you can just dump it out and
then have bigquery just take you know
pointer to a GCS bucket of your choice
and then you put the data into bigquery
and then my slides are ghosting I don't
know what's going on with that but but
just imagine that we have that slide on
use cases and the last use case that I
am talking about is Bitcoin so why just
talk about it when we can actually see
it in action so please welcome Steve
onstage was one of the lead engineers on
spanner who is here to help me drive
this demo with you I'm gonna stand way
over here so if you're not familiar with
spanner this is our cloud console I'm
very proud of it it's very clean and we
are actually in a cloud spanner instance
which is a collection of resources and
also a configuration unit and this one
is called import/export demo instance
not very creative but informative and
we're looking at a YC SB database for
this demo so it's a very simple database
it has one one table with multiple keys
and it is two terabytes in this case
we've loaded two terabytes of data and
we're going to try and export and import
this database so so now you can see with
if you're familiar the console we have
two new buttons at the top one is an
import button and the other ones export
so let's first export this existing day
and at the click of a button magic
happens I think there's a Harry Potter
in this in the venue somewhere so
there's a button that got clicked and it
brought up a screen where you can simply
specify which GCS buckets you want to
put your data in and then you can
stiva selecting that again not imagine
that there but informative that's what
database people are and then we choose
the database we want in this case we
want the YC SB database and then we also
want to choose the compute region for
running the data flow compute jobs so
remember we're using our data our
platform data flow for doing this export
right and so you have to specify where
to create that it run the data flow jobs
in order to export this data out and
then you hit export and voila you have a
two terabyte database that that's being
exported right now so as you can see
here it brings you back to this instance
page for the database details page where
you can see the banner so the point is
no matter who you are and if you
navigate away from this page and come
back to it you will know that there's an
export happening right now currently and
so this is helpful if you're you know
you have a team of people looking at the
the instance in the database and you
want to know that something is happening
right now so you can actually go view
the data place job details from this
from this banner itself but we actually
have a handy dandy import-export tab so
that will maintain a history of all the
things that all the imports and exports
that you've done for this database and
so you can see there's one that's
running right now let's actually look at
in the interest of time and hopefully no
more magic happens let's look at an
existing data flow job that rants are
that ran previously and the idea here is
that we make it easy for you to debug
your data flow jobs so we just take you
to the page where the with the data flow
details and you can see how the data
flow JA ran what it did
and you can also see on the side panel
info pane that you know the how long it
took what type of worker auto-scaling
happened etc so this is helpful in
debugging your previous data flow jobs
and maybe optimizing them as your data
size grows or or things like that
so now let's going back to our instance
again
let's while this is running let's
actually do an import back into cloud
spanner as well so again Steve is
showing you how quickly he can go and do
an import where you can choose the
database of your choice where you want
to import it again you have to specify
the GCS bucket to import from and again
you have to choose a data flow region to
run those data flow jobs now to import
data back into cloud spanner right and
there's no magic here please no magic
but now we're importing this two
terabyte database again you can see the
job flow details on our handy dandy
import/export tab and again there's a
couple that failed you know we're being
honest here it's a live demo and you can
see that you know again there's this
import happening for this particular
database so that gives you a whirlwind
tour if we can switch back to the slides
maybe
[Music]
so that gave you a whirlwind tour of the
of the import/export functionality which
we released last week the next question
out maybe the 11th is is more about DML
right so this is the ability to do
sequel queries in the in in spanner
right so spanner allows you to do insert
update and delete obviously but through
the RPC API and and so far you couldn't
do it in sequel but I am very happy to
say that we're working on this
functionality so that you could do
sequel queries inside inside spanner so
what this means is that you can now use
your existing and standard traditional
tooling for databases including JDBC
drivers and other drivers and no RMS and
the spanner is looking and feeling and
smelling a lot more like your
traditional databases right so what with
this functionality you can do insert
update delete and sequel you can do
complex queries we will have this
functionality like with all kind of
functionality almost we'll have it in
the UI CLI and API and when we released
DML we will also support in the JDBC
driver that we already have so again
this is not about any timeline or
anything like that I just wanted to show
you that what we're working on and to
again while I talk about it when you can
when you can see it in action
so steve is gonna help me again with
with this demo if we can switch the
screens thank you so I'm gonna stand way
over here this time again we're back to
the query console and we are looking at
a different database so yeah so we're
looking at a different database this
time which is a ticket info database so
this is a little bit more interesting
than the YC sp1 as you can see on the
side the schema shows that we have event
table account table ticket table etc so
it's an you know fairly standard
database and event table here has two
in the seas as well so let's run a query
to see what events we have so in the
query console you can run sequel queries
and you can see the result right here
and as you can see the main thing here
is that there isn't any multi event ID
set so if you go to the explanation
actually you can see that it's using an
event by date index so it's doing the
right thing to be running the query
efficiently and if we go back now let's
do something interesting with this table
which is to change the multi event ID
for all events that start yesterday to
cloud next because cloud next started
yesterday so a DML quarry completed and
again if you look at the query plan now
we support DML operations in the query
plan through apply mutation sorry I hope
you can see this and just to make sure
that we're not fooling you let's
actually see the event table again and
hopefully we'll see multi event ID being
updated for all events that are starting
as of yesterday look it got updated
boo-boo
so DML actually works and now let's do
something a little bit more interesting
because I have a bunch of question there
customers who say well but will you be
able to do conditionals and where
clauses and if clauses and all that sort
of stuff in your distributed database
that can by the way is killed to
petabyte scale databases so here we have
the attendees table so basically we have
a list of attendees here and what we
want to do is mark all the attendees
that are coming to my session today
VIPs because we like you all so here we
can see that Alice and Carol are
attending the spanner session so we're
going to mark them as we add peace for
the rest of the event
now disclaimer this doesn't actually
hook into the actual events for today so
you won't be if you are Alice and Carol
you won't be a VIP unless you already
are but the idea here is that we should
be able to update this with the
conditional and add the VIP tag so let's
actually look at the query again and and
see if we can it doesn't matter
live demo people so basically we should
update this attendees table with with
VIP status for for Alice and Carol
perfect it works and we demonstrated
that we aren't canned right so that
gives you a whirlwind tour of our DML
functionality that we're working on it
should as I said give you a look and
feel for for off spanner similar to
other databases and should make it
easier for you to both migrate and then
use it with your existing tooling so
moving on another thing that is
frequently asked is performance tuning
right so this is common for all
databases everybody wants more I can
high-five you as well everybody wants
more insight into their database because
they know they can do better than what
the database is doing automatically no
matter what we think about our heuristic
algorithms so we're working on another
exciting new feature that I'm going to
have on a step up here and help me demo
on as one of the lead engineers for this
feature it's called query statistics
again this is something that's coming
soon we are planning to do to release it
later this year but I'm very excited
about it because it gives you
introspection into your worst performing
queries and there are multiple
additional dimensions along which we
report stats so you can see what's going
on with your queries and of course we'll
have this available in our API and our
UI in multiple granularity buckets so
let's see in an action if you could
switch please so we're back to our UI
console now I'm just doing it in the we
were just doing it in the UI console cuz
it's easier to see and understand but of
course we'll have it programmatically as
well so this is the same ticket info
schema that we saw earlier with the
account and event and
and whatnot but this time we have an
exciting new tab called query statistics
so what you can see when you get into
the query statistic tab is all of the
queries that ran in the last minute in
this case that are hogging the most CPU
so they're the most resource intensive
and we're looking at sorting them per
CPU and whereas cursor is basically we
have multiple buckets in which you can
see that so you can not only see what
happened in the last minute but the last
hour the last 24 hours etc but we're
gonna stick to the last minute and see
our top query so if you click on it you
can we actually give you a lot more
information on the side in our info
panel and as you can see the the query
took 261 CPU seconds it'll give you a
lot more information like you know
latency rows scanned and Rose sent now
in this case they're both the same which
means that the query was not doing any
aggregations of filtering and if you
look at the handy dandy query text on
the top you can see that indeed it was
not doing any aggregations and filtering
but it is using a parameterised it is a
parameterize query and this is a good
time to talk about using parameterised
queries because they are actually make
your queries perform more efficiently
because the query engine can store the
query plan and not have to rebuild it
every time you run the query it also
gives us better statistics for things
like crazy stats and you know even if
you invoke the query multiple times it
will store the information for you
because it's using the same plan right
so in this case the query was run in the
last minute 150,000 times almost and all
of that is aggregated and put together
in this query statistics so let's look
at a more interesting query so let's
look at you know all the venues by
seeding capacity and in this case you
can see that the total CPU here taken
was 24 seconds but the average CPU is
much much less than that and what that
means is the spanner
which is meant to distribute is meant to
be paralyzing queries is actually doing
that and so giving you the response in
much shorter time even though the
execution counter is much smaller so you
know it's just another query in your top
10 queries so what if you wanted to
debug this query and see what it did in
real time so you can click on this
button to open into our query console
very very cool I think we are database
geeks so what makes this what make what
we think is cool is not necessarily cool
for everybody but as you can see here
you know the query ran in this case and
it gave us a list of all the venues with
seating capacity and if you wanted to
debug it you would want to look at the
query explanation as well to see what
it's doing right and this is the explain
plan for this particular run of the
query of course and you can see it's
doing you know all the things you expect
to do it's doing a hash and an
aggregation to to return the results to
you in descending order
cool so hopefully that was that was a
fun demo for you all of what we're
working on thank you Anna and Steve for
running those demos for us and if we can
switch back right so those are some very
exciting features one of the two
exciting features that we're working on
that I wanted to show to you all to make
sure you understand there we are
listening to you and we are working on
things and we plan to release both of
these in the next on in the next couple
months okay so before we end I wanted to
also address a couple of points that
I've heard over the past year that we've
been around and and talked about some of
the myths that I see happening so I
wanted to do a little bit of
myth-busting series class kind of really
the right app right database for your
app I hear this a lot you know cloud
spanner is meant only for very large
workloads and the fact is that spanner
is actually built so that you
start with it and never have to re
platform right
the idea is fire-and-forget you you
start with it and then you never have to
think about charting or which scale
versus performance versus name your your
thing that you care about because it can
just grow with your application so you
want to focus on getting the next
billion users we're right there with you
we can help you grow as you grow right
in fact what we've seen is that and this
is a known statistic like most average
enterprise database sizes are you know
hundreds of gigabytes and you know up to
a terabyte or two and average clouds
metadata business sizes are right in
that smack in the middle of that right
we have one database or that is 35
terabytes and it's growing great but the
idea is that you're you can use spanner
for the entire spectrum because you're
getting the benefit of a managed
database that is scaleable that is
parallelizable that is secure all in one
package right we have regional
configurations and multi vision
configurations right if whichever one
you use is great great multi vision
configurations offer higher availability
if that's what you want
and they can lower latency so you can
use it as a content distribution system
for your transactional data right if
that's what you want but but that has
nothing to do with size right it's to do
with your requirements and making the
right choice for your requirements and
also as I said with import/export
functionality for example if you started
out with a regional instance and we
thought oh I actually need to be multi
region because you know I'm now popular
everywhere in the world and I really
want to you know grow my healthcare
business all over the world then you can
just take a snapshot move it to a multi
moving configuration so cloud spanner is
being used for typical enterprise and
other database workloads and we can
expect for it to continue to do that
right
the other thing I hear quite often is
cloud spanner is expensive and when you
look at total cost of ownership actually
in most cases cloud spammers actually
gives you great value for your money
right because it's fully managed you
don't have to have teams of people
carrying pagers or if you're a start-up
and you have one person that person
carrying pagers all the time there's no
plan down time there's no patches or
upgrades to be added or whatever it's
high availability it's replicated and it
has security and compliance built in we
don't nickel and dime you and say you
know if you you get this but if you want
this you have to pay me you know so much
more and then so much more and then so
much more right we want to be open and
transparent and give you the best
platform for your applications and not
have to have you worry about what is my
monthly bill gonna look like right and
of course you know storage auto scale so
you never have to provision storage and
more importantly you don't have to bring
your entire database down to provision
the storage right and you can scale up
and down the compute as you need right
as you want to go so you can actually
increase compute on demand if you have
expected high load because it's Black
Friday or whichever Mother's Day or
whatever and you can tune it down when
you need for lower you know for lower
number of nodes if you need that so you
you have elastic compute and you have
Auto scale and storage in a fully
managed secure compliant database right
and of course Brad mentioned this
earlier in the keynote today but we are
industry-leading in our SLA so we have
four nines of SLA for regional fine
lines of SLA for multi region and as I
said you future proof your apps because
you start with spanner and you don't
have to reap lat form ever
right so that is all I had
[Music]
you